la crise des migrants mer méditerranée
des immigrants qui tente en fait vous
savez de rejoindre l'europe ne cesse
d'augmenter
demeure un enjeu vraiment majeur le 20
décembre dernier à 162 migrants qui ont
été secourus par le navire humanitaire
ocean drive kings de los angeles ouest
méditerranée
d'ailleurs on retrouve à marseille en
france frédéric pénard et les directeurs
des opérations de sos méditerranée
bonjour monsieur bénard bonjour alors un
autre sauvetage quelques jours avant
noël je disais 162 personnes dont une
cinquantaine de mineurs
cinq femmes enceintes dans quel état
était de 6 écoutez les personnes qu'on a
ainsi couru juste avant noël comme vous
le disiez sont des personnes qui étaient
sur deux embarcations en détresse au
milieu de la méditerranée centrale donc
on se situe entre le sud de l'italie
malte et le nord de la libye
en plein milieu de la haute mer on était
à plus de 60 kilomètres des côtes pour
premier sauvetage à plus de 100 km pour
le deuxième
ces gens étaient dans un bateau en
caoutchouc très très fragile plus de 112
personnes sur le premier sauvetage et
puis ensuite c'était une barque en bois
très instable il faut dire que l'on est
en plein hiver en ce moment méditerranée
centrale la météo était très défavorable
et les personnes étaient donc perdu au
milieu de cette haute mer les gens ont
eu énormément de chance de pouvoir
croiser la route de l'eau chaude biking
qui les a secourus
juste avant noël comme vous le disiez un
2019 vous avez effectué le 19 sauvetage
en mer ça représente énormément
personnes que vous avez pu se courir
oui ce sont mille trois cent soixante
treize personnes qui ont été secourus
par le shangai king est porté en lieu
sûr en italie et à malte
ce sont mille trois cent soixante treize
personnes depuis août 2019
parce que auparavant sos méditerranée
avait perdu son bateau précédent mais
depuis la création de notre association
en 2015 ce sont plus de trente mille
personnes que nous avons pu se courir
dans cette mer méditerranée qui reste l'
axe maritime le plus mortel au monde
d'après toutes les statistiques
peu importe le nombre de départs qu'il
ya de moins en moins de départ le fait
que personne ne vienne en assistance
auprès de ces personnes qu'elles
seulement quelques bateaux s'il fait que
c'est cette mer est extrêmement
dangereuse et et les gens meurent et
pour la plupart ils parlent de fuir la
libye
oui absolument la grande manne l'immense
majorité des personnes qui nous avons
secouru jusqu'à aujourd'hui sont des
personnes qui nous raconte toujours la
même histoire depuis quatre ans
maintenant
elles fuient la libye elle fuit des
conditions terribles qui sont très
documenté aujourd'hui par les nations
unies par tous les états de l'union
européenne
les personnes en migration se retrouvent
coincés dans des centres de détention
des centres de détention officiels où
elles sont relativement mal traitée mais
surtout des centres de détention non
officiel où ces personnes sont victimes
de tous les abus on parle de torture on
parle de viol on parle de travail forcé
ces personnes sont parfois emprisonnés
pendant des mois des années
et puis elle fuit à un moment quand
elles quand elles le peuvent elles
fuient sur des embarcations extrêmement
fragiles vers le nord vers l'europe
effectivement et c'est dans cette mer
méditerranée centrale que nous leur
portons secours lorsque nous les
trouvons vous paraît d'embarcations
fragiles sont des dd fut et est
extrêmement risquée des opérations de
sauvetage également période on n'imagine
pas évident à trouver toutes ces
personnes en mer comme ça c'est
extrêmement technique c'est le seul
endroit au monde où de telles opérations
de sauvetage ont lieu
on parle de sauvetages parfois
d'embarcations de plus de 100 personnes
il faut imaginer que au milieu de la
haute mer c'est à dire quand on ne voit
rien d'autre qu'une cote qu' aucune côte
à l'horizon il faut pouvoir approcher
ces embarcations gérer la panique des
gens gérer les urgences et faire en
sorte que cette situation qui est
extrêmement instable ne tourne pas au
cauchemar avec des embarcations qui se
casse qui se renverse qui chavire qui se
dégonfle il faut savoir que ce sont des
embarcations extrêmement extrêmement
pauvre de passe de fabrication très très
très très aléatoire et on a vu
malheureusement dans l'histoire des
sceaux s méditerranée plus d'une fois
ces embarcations ont chaviré à notre
approche sa cause et termina le rap est
aujourd'hui visé sur l'accueil des
migrants rescapés comme un s'annonce
2020 écoutez l'europe divisée elle est
parfois malheureusement depuis quelques
temps bien unis pour ne rien faire
l'europe laisse cette frontière sud de
son continent complètement vide
simplement quelques organisations
civiles ong comme la nôtre sont là pour
pour preuve porter assistance alors que
c'est le devoir de tous les marins en
haute mer porter assistance aux
personnes en danger l'europe aujourd'hui
brille par son inaction
il ya très peu de d'initiatives qui sont
prises les bateaux militaires européens
qui patrouillait dans la zone ont été
retirés en 2019 donc l'année 2020
malheureusement commence sous de biens
mauvais auspices
aujourd'hui le seul petit espoir que
nous avons c'est que l'europe arrive à
comprendre que ce sont ces valeurs qui
coule en méditerranée plus qu'autre
chose et qu'elle qu'elle réalise un
petit peu
un système un petit peu plus efficace
qu'elle met des moyens et qu'elle
organise notamment la possibilité pour
les bateaux civils de débarquer en lieu
sûr comme l'exigent le droit maritime
c'est c'est ce que nous demandons depuis
maintenant de nombreux mois de
nombreuses années donc c'est un peu mais
le vert à des décisions de la part des
autorités des différents pays frédéric
renard directeur des opérations de sos
méditerranée merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce bilan et on vous
souhaite une excellente année 2010 merci
bonne journée